jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour le débat
commence maintenant sur bfmtv débat très
attendu c'est comme ça qu'on veut dire
avec ça
[Musique]
salut c'est fabien de 2021 qui fait un
retour dans le temps en 2016 mais
vraiment j'ai l'impression de revivre
l'année du mental l'aube où je faisais
une vidéo par jour en gros je suis dans
mes loge de spectacles en tournée je
suis à longjumeau et à l'époque du
mandat le bloc c'était ça aussi mais
j'enregistrais souvent les vidéos dans
les loges avec la legria minix qui la
caméra qui utilisent aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce qu'on a reçu mas
commentaires de fabien fait une analyse
zemmour mélenchon je n'ai pas eu le
temps de regarder le débat donc je vais
découvrir leur l'analyse et puis j'ai
appelé loïc j'ai dit est ce qu'on fait
est ce qu'on a le temps de le faire et
me dit non mais faisons bleus quand même
quelqu'un qui m'a dit tu fais la vidéo
est distant avec alegria on s'en fout tu
m'envoies ça je fais un montage et il
faut qu'on la sort dans pas trop
longtemps sinon ça plus de sens il avait
raison donc c'est parti on va faire ça
là maintenant analyser mon mélenchon
mais attention le petit disclaimer de
d'habitude c'est maintenant ce que je
fais ça s'appelle une analyse non
verbale qui va prendre aussi en compte
le verbal et le para verbal attention
dans le sac de ti que j'utilise il ya
des outils qui sont très controversés et
à juste titre du style la synergologie
où il ya 90 % ht la pnl où il ya pas mal
de trucs qui sont pas bons non plus donc
j'essaie de faire attention mais au
final ça donne une analyse très
personnelle en fait très subjective ce
que je dis c'est pas une vérité ok c'est
c'est un mélange de choses que je crois
de choses qui sont sûres et de choses
qui sont pseudo scientifiques alors ça
donne cet amalgame cette analyse que
vous allez voir maintenant
l'ald riscle et bonsoir il était
intéressant on a eu un mélenchon très
sérieux très posé donc très candidats
qui vient en fait un débat présidentiel
entre guillemets et on a un zemmour qui
est des plus souriants plus malicieux
plus détendue dans sa gestuelle ça peut
aussi cacher attention un certain stress
mais qui vient faire ce qu'il a
l'habitude de faire en fait exprimé des
idées pour qu'on voit déjà qu'ils sont
pas sur la même longueur d'onde sur leur
présence ici et après chacune de ces
parties
cellules de fact checking va intervenir
une équipe de dizaines de journalistes
qui vont écouter très attentivement vos
affirmations et qui vérifieront aussi
les chiffres que vous allez avancé c'est
intéressant ça alors ça existe peut-être
déjà mais c'est la première fois moi que
je vois en direct en fait du fact
checking sahara change complètement la
donne en fait en réalité de ce que tu
peux te dire ou pas ce que tu peux
affirmer ou pas parce qu en temps réel
on peut avoir une correction de
vérification c'est très intéressant nous
allons écouter décortiquer vérifier les
propos des débatteurs et vous livrez
nous c'est assez marrant là je fais
pause mais mais regardez les les
sourires sont différents mélenchon il a
quand même un truc d'assises à ce moment
là en mode j'ai mes notes et alors moi
on va pas m'avoir et en un amour qui a
changé de position depuis le départ il
était comme ça plutôt en fait du cours à
l'écouté que sita qui du coup se
redresse relève un peu le montant que
des filles 3 les bras des styles eux
c'est pas un problème mais il ya un côté
de ses bras un problème mais que
peut-être que je fasse attention je
donnerai pas de chiffres et en vrai
c'est pas là dessus qu'il est né hier
d'ailleurs c'est pas surfaite donner les
chiffres autant de paroles messieurs
devront être à égalité à la fin de ce
débat on y verra une question une
question en préambule eric zemmour
pourquoi avoir accepté de débattre ce
soir avec jean vie mais l'enfant j'ai
jamais
réclamé ce débat avec jean le gall un
jour parce que je pense que lui comme
moi nous sommes des gens qui qui est mon
histoire qui la connaissons jean luc
mélenchon pourquoi avoir accepté ce
débat et même j'irai plus loin l'avoir
provoquée
c'est marrant parce que les éléments de
langage utilisé avec zemmour laissé
entendre que c'est lui qui veut débattre
avec des gens et que c'est lui qui est à
l'initiative est en fait là ce que dit
la journaliste c'est jean luc mélenchon
qui a provoqué du coup et initier le
débat du coup je sais pas du tout lequel
deux de quel détruites récemment qu'on
attribue au dessus
je suis candidat et les occasions de
convaincre doivent de toutes ces vies la
france entre le 9ème siècle après les
grandes invasions jusqu'au 19ème siècle
a été une population très stable à
partir des années 1860 à cause du pour
l'instant pas grand chose à dire sur le
jeu sur le non verbal en lui-même par
contre quelque chose de très intéressant
c'est que on voit que depuis les vingt
premières minutes de débat environ il ya
eric zemmour qui pointent tous les
éléments du passé donc qui qui qui fait
des topos passéiste on va dire et jean
luc mélenchon qui lui ne fait que des
projections sur le futur mais c'est
normal il est candidat il a un programme
libre et je trouve que ça se ressent en
fait le côté pour l'instant pas de
programme pour eric zemmour qui va
peut-être lui donnait des difficultés
plus tard on va voir ça mais en tout cas
il ya une vraie différence de
temporalité entre 1 qui se focalise sur
le passé et un autre qui se focalise sur
le futur ce qui fait qu'il ya personne
dans le présent de mai vous avez une
vision de l'islam qui est assez
les religions exemple la bible c'est
vraiment parce que non vous n'y
connaissez rien il fait un truc que jean
luc mélenchon très souvent ils regardent
les journalistes et revient comme ça sur
sur son opposant et c'est assez marrant
de voir ça parce que en faisant ça ils
envoient un signal de on est tous
d'accord avec ça vous ne pouvez pas
aller contre mon opinion comme s'il y
avait une connivence établi est évident
que les journalistes n'ont pas avoir de
connivence avec les personnes qu adam et
ils forcent à simuler une connu une
connivence ce qui fait que nous ça nous
paraît encore plus crédible encore une
fois je juge ni le fonds ni rien du tout
de ce que dit mélenchon aux est mort
c'est pas c'est pas du tout mon délire
point de faire ça c'est une analyse de
forme c'est assez marrant de voir à quel
point ça amuse et moi qui lui pour le
coup et sur son terrain il est vraiment
en appui c'est pas de l'appui de j'ai
besoin de me reposer c'est de la
stabilité en fait qu il a à ce moment là
en mode si on voit des trucs gd chose en
retour
si nous n'avançons pas maintenant dans
cette première partie nous sommes là
jusqu'à minuit et demi je vous propose
donc maintenant vous avez rattraper
votre retard en partie dans lesquels ont
en partie je vais vous donner la parole
tout de suite vous allez voir pas besoin
de mots pour voir le somment de
mélenchon co yvois qui va pas pouvoir
terminer alors que lui dans sa tête il
avait calculé qu'il lui restait une
minute encore pour rattraper le temps de
parole qui doit être équilibré dont qui
il était en train de faire sa
préparation argumentaire il avait après
ses dernières conclusions qui sont
celles qui sont censé convaincre mais
aboutir la crainte et raisonnement et on
vient de lui enlever on a vu le seul
avec son tube de sécurité insécurité qui
fait partie évidemment des
préoccupations des français et oui il ya
de l'insécurité je vous annonce qu'il y
en aura toujours plus à mesure qu'il y
aura toujours plus de misère et plus de
désagrégation de l'école publique par
conséquent la question à se poser c'est
d'abord d'être capable de mesurer
personne ne fait jamais aucun bilan on
met du monde et toujours plus de monde
quel est le résultat ça va de plus en
plus mal à celle du rallye jean luc
mélenchon quand il fait ses prises de
parole il est tellement rodé à
l'exercice
il est très bon quoi dans le personnage
qui qui qui l'incarnent politiquement
parlant
ignorance bien sa voix il a les
gestuelles qu'il faut là où il faut il
fait ses placements de regard quand
comme il veut donc après on a juste le
fond du débat et encore une fois je suis
pas là pour ça mais du coup il est assez
dur en fait à juger par contre ça c'est
assez assez marrant que de voir que que
eric zemmour qui pour l'instant
polémiste lui s'est toujours pas
présenté un même si on pressent que ça
va être le gars est du coup lui la plus
serrée actions de visages de polémistes
de oui c'est ça oui bien sûr ou là de se
relever en vient alors à salé c'est ça
que vous les liens et là on a le début
d'une micro expressions d'étonnement
avec même l'ouverture un peu d'élèves
j'allais dire il nous manque ça mais non
aussi jeu que de savoir comment ça va
réagir par conséquent ça veut dire non
pas que les gens sont coupables mais que
la force et mal employé vous nous donner
des chiffres bizarre mais nos faces
shaker professionnels le vérifierons moi
je vous en donne est donc si vous me
permettez dans les années 60 c'est
exactement ce que faisait tard il
revient à chaque fois au passé c'est ma
- là on l'a bien vu sur cette séquence
la cua mélenchon qu'on voit sur le futur
sur ce qu'il faut corriger pour le futur
est lui directement dans les années 60
c'est le csat houle aujourd'hui il y en
a 60 pour 1000 habitants mille la grée
sion par jour en france et à des
terribles la position de jean luc
mélenchon il l'a fait plusieurs fois
depuis tout à l'heure c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça comme ça comme ça c'est
vraiment le sais pas je m'en fous mais
tu sais que ça déstabilise l'otan mode
aller raconte des trucs vraiment raconte
je sais pas si c'est fait sciemment mais
je pense que oui je pense qu'il ya une
côte et petites stratégies de 10 t truc
c'est ton moment mais je m'en fous
mais c'est en vérité votre phrase est
honteuse pour les gens pauvres et qui ne
sont pas délinquants par ailleurs
pardonnez-moi mais la violence est n'est
pas le fait de pauvres vous entendez la
prosodie la d'eric zemmour sa manière de
parler par rapport à d'habitude eric
zemmour et beaucoup toujours plus fluide
il est toujours plus appuyé il a un fond
d'idées
des fois il le contourne pour qu'on
comprenne idée globale en tout cas il y
va c'est là des premières fois en tout
cas et là ça fait quarante minutes de
débat qu il est 6 h et 6 h huré pas ta
ta ta ta rembourrés tout découpé et
remonter comme on veut tellement il ya
de blanc entre chacun des mots et c'est
intéressant ça me fait un parallèle avec
le tennis figurez vous je pense qu'eric
zemmour en donc polémiste il a habitué
en fait à des débats de des rapides pas
minutes une demi heure des choses comme
ça il n'est pas habitué à faire des
grands chelems à faire en fait des
durées très longues là on doit être sûr
2h20 de débat c'est pas quelque chose de
courant chez lui en fait alors que pour
le coup mélenchon qui est sûrement moins
bon que lui en fait sur les enrobages
sur les storytelling etc il est
complètement rodez en fait à des débats
qui dure 2h 3h 4h et cette petite
puissance qui apparaît c'est même
physiquement sur eric zemmour dans le
début du débat elle risque en fait de
changer quand la à partir de maintenant
en tout cas c'est la première fois qu'on
le voit en train de hachures et alors
que jean luc mélenchon dans sa prise de
parole lui ne perd toujours pas saverne
et sa puissance gestuelle aujourd'hui un
nom français
donnez moi je n'ai
par exemple
qui n'est pas français
je suis français beaucoup d'étrangers
vous savez combien d'étrangers dans
l'épopée dans les prisons françaises 25%
la mise en difficulté de mélenchon qui a
pointé le truc mais en même temps la
porte était grande ouverte on l'a vu un
peu pataugé là-dessus eric zemmour de
dire oui bon bah mon nom il pas français
au départ ce qu'il est ce qu'ils
entendent qui serait français maintenant
son nom alors que dans sa logique à lui
effectivement il est pas français c'est
ce qu'il a nommé et je cherchais à voir
comment il allait trouver sa porte de
sortie on le voit comme la
l'illumination dans son oeil où il fait
oui mais de deux paires les étrangers
c'est ce qu'elle a prise en prison mais
c'était pas le débat dit non à un jeu
continue et après les mains jointes de
jeu continue c'est en fait c'est la
protection des droits sur le devant de
et maintenant on insiste plus et laisse
voix déroulée ma partie joli c'est tout
à l'heure un article sur les mineurs
isolés l'un d'entre eux qui est arrêté
dit nous voulons piller la france vous
voyez la dent dans les sourires et les
expressions de visage de satisfecit de
satisfaction on voit que la zemmour se
sent plus à l'aise même les mains elle
commence à se détendre avec les pouces
qui se décroisent sur le dessus pourquoi
parce qu'il va dans ce qui s'est le
mieux le faire et c'est l'impact qui a
derrière c'est un storytelling d'un
événement sur mon réel d'ailleurs et il
aime se ranger derrière parce que on de
parents mettent en cause quelque chose
qui s'est passé là où mélenchon encore
une fois on le voit depuis tout à
l'heure lui est plus fragile par contre
dans ses impacts parce qu'il vient
défendre des idées les idées politiques
d'un programme politique là aussi ça
fait ressortir le fait qu'on en a un
pour l'instant qui cherche juste d'avoir
l'opinion publique de son côté eric
zemmour sans programme derrière du coup
et est un mélenchon qui cherche à avoir
des voix
ça commence à être intéressant souvenez
vous ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure sur le fait de tenir dans la
longueur donc là on voit encore jean luc
mélenchon cherche pas de rythme change
pas d'intensité change pas de voix par
contre dans le non verbal d'eric zemmour
ça vraiment ça s'est affaissé depuis le
départ on a des positions qu'on ne
connaissait pas les mains devant la
bouche on s'empêche de parler et surtout
on commence à voir des mouvements de
pied s'il ya des plans larges on le
verra quelle impasse rapporté bref son
compte dernier à une sorte de relégation
sociale beaucoup de gestes parasites là
juste là encore zemmour qui reprend
contact avec lui même la contradiction
qu'il faut régler
je ne crois pas que même son temps de
démarrage les un petit peu plus longue
d'habitude ça veut dire qu'il ya des
petites décroche mental
les pousses qui bouge beaucoup chose
qu'on n'avait pas tout à l'heure non
plus bas et les pieds qu'il dit j'ai
énormément
alors
en synergologie on dirait c'est comme
s'ils patauger ça c'est de la pseudo
science fait c'est rigolo de deux de se
rappeler sa de l'allemagne et des états
unis quarante ans plus tard
nous avons là des blancs qui fait 1h10
ça commence à fatiguer à déplacer 12
millions de personnes dans la région de
francs
par an comment il sert et angéla eric
zemmour il s'est fait ranger on l'a vu
vraiment physiquement se ranger je veux
demander c'était pour faire une attaque
ou pas non lui il s'est fait ranger
parce que jean luc mélenchon un flou
trop fort et il a monté une d'au moins
10 15 % le volume de sa voix depuis tout
à l'heure donc là où il y en a un qui en
fait les énergies l'hôte est en montée
d'énergie ya la chance y'a pas eu de
trop gros problème il y en a beaucoup
c'est marrant il a même adopté
maintenant la position par mimétisme
ster qu'il a récupéré la la position de
jean luc mélenchon ce qui veut dire que
peut-être pas sur le fond encore une
fois je fou je suis pas là pour ça mais
sur la forme jean luc mélenchon a un
tout petit dit pas grand chose parce que
ils sont vraiment à égalité là depuis
depuis une heure 33 maintenant une plaie
quand même à force d'insistance et à
force de le saouler il lui a envoyé ça
sauf que ce qu'on a l'habitude de voir
sur jean luc mélenchon et qu'on prend
pour du mépris on peut le prendre la
pente de la faiblesse et de la fatigue
d'eric zemmour en tout cas de l'abandon
de l'abandon de toute manière ne laisse
jamais parler et puis qui déroule mais
c'est intéressant de voir qu'il a
récupéré cette position
évidemment un bon départ et juge qui
s'appelle le conseil constitionnel qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle qui s'appelle la
cour de justice
c'est énorme là il est il qu'il son
adversaire qui ne l'écoutent pas c'est à
dire que mélenchon vraiment en train de
noter ses trucs de son côté etc et est
du coup il n'est qu' un regard
journalistes il cherche un petit peu
d'appuis en fait pour reprendre un peu
de de puissance et un peu de force qui
semblait non monsieur mélenchon comme
toute la gauche d'ailleurs n'a jamais
digéré la disparition de la quatrième
république et il veut remettre sous
couvert de souveraineté populaire et
d'abattre la monarchie faire switcher
c'est en fait c'est un match nul pour le
coup quoi ces illégalités deux côtés ça
regardez comment la yang donc zemmour
qui a repris sa force et c'est parce que
l'art et les sur son terrain 10h mois il
a récupéré en plus de l'appui sur les
journalistes il a compris que ça ça
marchait sur lui parce qu'au 6e ont
plusieurs réactions sûrement et alors
que mélenchon en a récupéré sa fameuse
position avec ses yeux foncés de la même
manière et sont visibles les hommes et
l'enchantement
king
notes parce que j'ai le tableau en face
de moi oui bon
j'ai pas besoin d'être cabinet
d'un cd foule a le devoir autant de
sourires sur les deux c'est à dire que
là comme l'autre montrent bien au final
que tout ça c'est un jeu c'est un jeu
politique et puis nous aussi on en a
conscience dire qu'on sait qu'ils
incarnent leur rôle à ce moment du débat
là on a une petite sortie de débats ou
mélenchon du coup cabotine peut-être
avec calcul vers cabotine pour s'attirer
la sympathie des autres regardez je suis
comme vous en faites et du coup je fais
les petites blagues comme bautista par
contre eric zemmour c'est assez marrant
de voir à quel point y rit énormément
nerveusement ça traduit en fait une
pression intérieure quand même ça de lui
demander au peuple quand même aussi
beaucoup de ressources et c'est normal
de rester deux heures comme ça concentré
en débat et c'est trop de rire trop de
sourires on pourrait penser qu'ils qu'en
fait ils sont potes même des
chiffres
mais non personne noire je suis content
mais en train de refaire le truc à
l'envers mélenchon de dire vrai si on me
dit qu'il ya deux façons de rabat en bas
je me se tromper alors que juste avril a
dit bon ben ok je vous entends mais je
pense que c'est faux alors c'est faux
c'est même impossible de passer l'hiver
dans le noir je pense que les gens qui y
vivent les situations j'ai connu
d'apprendre que c'est pas ce qui leur
arrive
de face ils vont dire les la train de
genlis à déni c'est jean jacques bourdin
qui va trés pendant il est solide en
paix où ces visites et vous remercier
pour la parfaite loyauté de
l'organisation de ce débat où tout ce
qui a été convenu a été tenu dans le
souci que chacun puisse dire ce qu'il a
à dire et c'est ce qui s'est passé
on a eu quand même ce truc c'est le
dernier coup de l'ide où il ya mélenchon
qui félicite l'organisation et la
loyauté et c'est tout ça et il prend la
main en ça en fait il est le promis à
remercier et à féliciter parce qu'il a
l'habitude encore une fois de sa et
directement il tourne le dos c'est à
dire que pour lui ça s'arrête là et du
coup zemmour qui veut pas être en reste
parce qu'en plus il je pense qu'ils
pensent ça aussi en tout cas il avait
l'air sincère à ce moment il ya des
signes de sincérité dit oui c'est vrai
moi aussi je le pensais que c est lui
devient en fait le seul à rester dans
cette bulle là parce que mélenchon s'est
tourné pour lui c'est terminé les
journalistes sont déjà en train
d'annoncer la suite et donc ce mot de la
fin est un mot faible du coup il s'est
fait grignoter un tout petit peu il ya
eu moins de choses à dire que prévu je
pensais que ce serait plus animé un
petit peu comme quand on avait fait
l'analyse du dic les bases et moore moix
que je vous mettrai aussi en lien dans
la description si j'y pense sinon mettez
le vous même pour les autres je les
peins je l'aurais mais où là c'était
vraiment flagrant quoi là c'étaient
d'autres enjeux quoi c'était c'était
assez marrant d'autres enjeux avec aussi
un passéiste 1 qui projeter dans le
futur aucun des deux côtés dans le
présent un qui est candidat déclaré
l'autre qu'il ne l'est pas donc hic dans
sa fonction peut les y nice mais en même
temps dans le temps de parole et contre
le maintenant parce qu'on considère
qu'il fait de la politique
l'un qui est un programme long qui a une
idéologie à défend c'était très
particulier un qu'à l'habitude des
débats de longue durée l'aude qui a plus
l'habitude de se rendre la polémique et
aider et de manger en fait car c'est un
polémiste rapidement pour faire placer
ni ses idées qu'il ait tort ou raison
donc c'était intéressant à avoir par
contre il y avait pas trop de grosses
surprises non verbale parra verbal etc
j'espère que ça vous a plu ce genre
d'analysé besoin d'un peu plus dans les
commentaires c'est comme d'habitude je
vous en mets deux anciennes ici et ici
et puis abonnez-vous évidemment à la
chaîne si vous le souhaitez mais fait
bien ce que vous voulez de votre vie
prenez soin de vous guy rendez vous
lundi prochain ou vendredi prochain
suivant le temps que je mette à monter
la vidéo si elle sort avant lundi la
prochaine vidéo sera lundi ciel della
sera vendredi la prochaine vidéo sera
vendredi prenez soin de vous c'était le
retour en 2016 en termes de set up à
très bientôt charles